each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
it's really a great pleasure to
introduce Carl Gunter to you he is well
known in a variety of work he did in the
security area he worked for government
with government had a good press on some
of his projects he started a company I
know him for long many years and he used
to be at the University of Pennsylvania
but few years ago he moved to the
University of Illinois and I guess one
of his new projects welcomed a
generalization of some work that I'm
doing jointly with this collection here
of colleagues at the University of
Illinois the purpose of the talk here is
that I wanted to discuss attribute-based
systems for security and in particular
to look at their illustration in a
particular system that we've been
developing the goal in part is to try to
delineate some of the difference between
what this refers to and what you might
call classic security systems and the
advantages of these systems are you know
in areas of Management and formalization
and for new middleware and applications
and I hope this illustrates some of the
kind of idea there the illustration in
here is based on attribute-based Mis
messaging which I'll now explain so an
attribute based messaging system sends
emails to parties described in terms of
it basically a database query is the
email address it's useful for enterprise
systems where you might have access to
an enterprise database that contains
information about principles that could
be used as the basis for these addresses
so it's a little bit like a listserv
except that the recipients are
dynamically determined by the address
and so it's as if you create a listserv
dynamically on the fly from the
enterprise database so in this case you
could have something like an email
message to all the female graduate
students in engineering who have passed
their qualifying exam
could be sent out and it would go to
that targeted group so the advantages of
things like this are first of all I
don't know about you but I get a lot of
irritating enterprise messaging that is
basically spam but my spam filter
refuses to catch I mean you know but
where it's hard to filter out and part
of the reason for that is that people
send messages to broad mailing lists
even though they may be for only fairly
limited groups of people and so an
efficiency thing here would be that you
could try to target things more
precisely for the people who actually
need the message like if you needed to
send a message to all the faculty on
sabbatical a typical way to do that now
would be to send it to all the faculty
but it would be nice if you could avoid
you know 6/7 of the wasted messages that
you would send that way both in terms of
the mainly in terms of the waste of the
time of the recipient who sees yet
another message that they really don't
care about another thing is exclusivity
which is a lot of the messages would go
to mailing lists that you'd like to be a
little more refined and sort of instead
of sending it to a big group you'd like
to send it to a smaller group maybe it's
something a little bit sensitive and you
do this kind of thing all the time
people create listserv things just for
specific groups because of the
sensitivity of the messages here this
can be done on fly so for example all
the tenured faculty serving on
conflict-of-interest committees of
course all of this is assuming that I do
actually have a database I can access
where that information is available so
I'll continue to assume that through
most of the talk here intentionality is
another feature which is it's often
easier to describe recipients of a
message than to actually list the
recipients so this is the old logical
distinction between intentionality and
extensionality so for example I might I
might or might not know who the
attending and ordering physicians are
for for Smith but maybe I don't really
care I just care that these are the
people that need the message and I don't
care who they are so I don't want to
know their email addresses now to do
this there are some design challenges
that come up one of them is access
control so this gives you a great power
to hit
targeted groups and so you asked on what
attributes should be able to send a
message so can you send a message to all
the faculty who make more than a hundred
fifty thousand dollars a year who if
anyone should be allowed to do that
maybe you could figure out who that list
is but you know not just anybody should
be able to send such a list undoubtedly
you could have like a super admin who's
the only person that can send such
messages but then that kind of wastes a
lot of the power here which would be
really something where you would allow a
broader group to use the facility under
a suitable access control system now
another one is encryption which is you
would ideally like to encrypt end-to-end
so that the mail relay if it's
compromised doesn't compromise your
sensitive messages but this is a major
technical problem if the sender's don't
know who of the specific recipients you
know and I gave examples there where
maybe you don't know or don't care or
shouldn't know then how do you encrypt
end to end for them okay and so that's a
question that some of the new
cryptography techniques can answer and a
third point and one that I'm not going
to go into in detail except to sort of
indicate a little bit about some of the
questions that come up here which is you
know should you know to whom you
actually sent the message so you know
their attributes but do you know who
they are and should you know why you got
a message like what attribute got me on
this mailing list and then you know you
can see up here things like if you got a
message like this and didn't know where
it came from and you answer it then if
you were supposed to keep it sensitive
who you know it's on the mailing list
and that information will be compromised
and so there's some tricky questions
about the information flows that would
occur here okay
so another thing about this is we had an
idea on this project that we wanted it
to be practical
others who were actually interested in
something you could use as opposed to
you know conjecturing a whole new type
of MTA or a client that you would have
to use and so it obvious kind of thing
is to implement this in webmail where
you can put all this stuff on a server
to do this but it was interesting to
think about how you could use existing
em UAS and mta's so that nobody has to
like use a special service to do this or
at least the special service they use
could be limited in some way like you
know just a web page to help them form
the address and then there are questions
about the efficiency of the access
control of the encryption and I'll get
to this question here about how you do
the cryptography the key generation is a
concern and then another point is that
if it's too complicated to either form
the addresses or to describe the
policies nobody's going to use it okay
so it really can't or you're going to
use it in a way that you know causes
harm and then people are going to stop
using it now the approach that we have
for this is to look at a combination of
these two technologies here I'm just
calling a back or attribute based access
control this has been around for a while
and I won't claim that it's something
completely new although I'll kind of
focus on some of the differences it has
with other things and in particular one
of our technologies here we were
interested in is something they call
policy special specialization which is
you don't want someone to send a message
and find out they're not allowed to send
it by it's being rejected you you want
somehow to tell people what they're able
to do in advance so they can never form
messages they're not allowed to send and
so that when they approach the system
you want to specialize a policy for them
it's a little bit like database views so
an individual approaches the database
you give them a view and then they can
query against that view you want
something similar to that in this
context the other one here is attribute
based encryption which is a relatively
new technology only a few years old for
encrypting in a collision resistant way
under attributes okay and so I'll
explain a little bit more about that as
I go along here now I this is the part
where I was going to try to get a little
bit of a distinction between these
techniques and other techniques this
could be a bit controversial I'll ask
you to indulge me for at least a little
while before we argue about whether this
is reasonable or not but the kind of
characteristic way of talking about
security is in terms of access lists or
capabilities and so here you might for
example have a table and you'd give a
list to the people who have access to
the table okay so they've groups you
know can be used for this to form the
Ackles better and yet in some cases you
would prefer to describe the policy more
intentionally that it's not in terms of
a list of people who have access but
maybe in terms of an attribute of the
people who should have access and then
the attributes might be something that
you could derive from the enterprise
database so if we wanted to give access
to a table to the managers you could
have a group of managers may be manually
maintained or you could have some link
between the manager attribute in the
enterprise system and the access control
and so if you do that kind of linkage it
introduces various problems but also
various advantages and a contrasting
thing here is role based access control
and one thing I'm often asked about this
is what's the difference between
attributes and roles and I think it's a
tough question to answer because there
are things that seem like they're
definitely roles things that seem like
they're definitely attributes and then a
lot of gray stuff in the middle so for
example being the chair of G and Chang's
thesis committee seems like a role to me
whereas being more than 21 years old
seems like an attribute to me I'm not
playing the role of being more than 21
years old and then there are things in
the middle where they seem a little bit
of each like being a professor okay so
I'd like to think of the roles as a
bundle of privileges often associated
with the task and when you need to
perform the task you activate the role
within the session in which you perform
the task and it gives a variety of
advantages in the management of
permissions but and you have techniques
like role hierarchies and definitions to
help you control the rules for what the
privileges are associated with the role
and who can occupy a role but places
often maintain argue that they don't
want to have to set up any special kind
of role system and so this is the thing
that I run into with organizations
saying well we're told we have to use
role based access control but you know I
don't like having to set up the roles
now so let me try to argue in favor of
this the of the
tribute based access control here and so
let's suppose that you have Alice and
she needs to get access to a table in a
database and so a way you could do this
with fine-grained access control is you
put a policy that refers to the database
and it may be the case it's quite common
to take the Akal of course and the Akal
is in the database and so in this sense
it's reflective so that the database
contains information it's about its own
access control however you often in
these systems see this is sort of
stratified so that the Akal is kind of
distinguished from the rest of the data
and so that the Akal could not for
example be modified by modifications of
other parts of the database and so that
process would require some additional
steps to make that happen
whereas what you often want is a lot of
information from the database to be used
in the decision so for example you would
have whoops
you would have data about Alice that's
being stored somewhere and then there
would be data about the data that's
being stored somewhere so this might be
that alice is a doctor and this might be
that you know Sally's data about her
patient record or EHR and then you might
have the relationship between the two
data which says that this is the doctor
of this and so you would like to do the
access control based on this combination
of things that's not a radical concept
of course what you would do is you write
say an application that manages this
access control with its own program
logic and it uses this information from
the database to make access control
decisions so that the particular thing
here that I wanted to kind of emphasize
is that we would like to go towards more
formal models of this kind of thing and
of middleware that can do this rather
than mixing it up in application logic
so the ideal thing would be to have say
a language for doing this sort of stuff
so that the security can be separated
out into that language and you can
reason about it now the process of
putting the Akal in the database with
fine-grained access control is so not
sustainable
that
there are quite a few supplements to
database systems to provide them some
kind of system to do more like this sort
of thing so for example the Oracle VPD
Virtual Private databases do something
like this but then I don't think that
it's very easy to take the Oracle VPD
system and and reason about it formally
and to understand it precisely and so
the one hopes that we can move a little
closer towards a more complete
understanding of these kinds of access
systems now looking at the kind of core
technologies here a back there's a lot
of established ideas on how to use
attributes and access control like I
said the idea is not radically new of
course one of the ones that was popular
was x.509 attribute certificates where
you could have an identity certificate
and then in order to avoid having to put
lots of information on it you separately
have a certificate that binds attributes
to the identity on the x.509 identity
certificate then you also see it like
for example in dynamic tokens like the
Shibboleth tokens carry attribute
information so you can use that for
authorization decisions in addition to
the identity information and as I was
mentioning before there's a lot of
implicit use in application servers
where you go into the database here to
get information about the principle you
go into the information there to get
information about you know the data
that's being accessed and so on there
are some new approaches one thing I was
kind of intrigued by I saw recently a
trade press article looking at health
information exchanges and urging the use
of attribute based access control
matrices in effect kind of to draw
access control matrices where the rows
and columns or descriptions of
attributes and so you'd say doctors have
access to lab results and so it's kind
of a generalization of an access control
matrix based on attributes those are
pretty limited though I would think that
you could not in such a language express
things like each doctor should have
access to their patients okay so that
you need something more sophisticated
another thing here is in trust
negotiation work this sort of popular
topic of how you swap credentials to
find
about each other gradually they've had a
fair amount of work on this use of
attributes to do those things and one
that we've been exploring is to look at
transaction data log as a foundation for
the reflective database access control
like I was showing on the previous slide
now attribute based encryption is and
it's it's data log in which there's an
operation to change the ground truth in
data log so their execution changes the
underlying true facts yeah the rules
change as part of that it allows you to
do things like suppose you wanted to
represent this thing about if if someone
ceases to be a manager do they lose a
privilege then you know you run the
thing and the database can change its
actual truths yeah so so it basically
gives you a way of modeling you know
both change and rules that depend on
ground truth okay so now this what we'll
be focusing here on something called
ciphertex policy attribute based
encryption which is a new set of
techniques for doing encryption on
attributes and I wanted to describe the
capability of this to you for those of
you haven't seen it before first of all
you represent attributes as strings so
you can use any any string as a as an
attribute it's possible to represent
types like boolean enumerated in
numerical ranges numerical ranges are
represented by like saying having three
attributes that are boolean for like the
first bit the second bit in the third
bed okay and so they're kind of costly
to do the numerical attributes but many
things need numerical attributes then
you have an attribute Authority who
issues individual private keys to users
based on their attributes so I would get
the professor key for example and then
you encrypt using something called an
access structure which is a tree with
thresholds so for example if you have
two children and the threshold is one
it's a disjunction and if it's two then
it's a conjunction and you then decrypt
you encrypt this using public parameters
and then you use the private keys in
order to decrypt if you happen to have a
satisfying collection of the private
keys and the hard part about this is the
protection against collusion so if I
send a message to tenured professors in
computer science then an assistant
professor in computer science can't
collude with a tenured professor in ECE
to get the thing decrypted in particular
the the way the private keys the the
faculty key that I have will be
different from the faculty key that
another member of the faculty has
because they have an individualized
attribute key but I won't go into the
details of how the cryptography is done
for this talk now let me turn back to
the ABM system and talk about that a
little bit so there are three key
policies that you get in the ABM system
so address is in our case and I'll just
talk about our design here but you could
have done this different ways are
disjunctive normal forms and you have
literals that assert equality's or
inequalities and you can write things
like the position is faculty and the
salary is more than 150-thousand for
example would be an address then this is
what we call a receiving policy it says
who you want to receive the message then
another step as we've talked about that
you know it's not possible to let
everybody send all these kinds of
messages is what you would call the
sending policy and what you do here is
you use a back rules to define the
attributes a party can use in an address
and here it's a kind of tricky design
and we did something fairly simple in
order to keep the thing more deployable
or easier to write so you could imagine
a complex access control system so that
any combination you might make to create
an address would be its own individual
access control but instead what we do is
simply have a condition that says
whether a particular attribute can be
set to a particular value and a message
you sent and then you're allowed to
combine those in any way you wish so for
example if I can route on faculty and I
can route on gender then I could always
you know if I had been able to route on
those individually you know just send a
message to both of the two lists with
some possible redundancy what's new here
if you would be able to route on the
intersection and send a message to the
female faculty okay
so there's some question as to whether
you know that would be an acceptable
policy all the time or not
we didn't think of really compelling
examples where we thought it was
objectionable okay so then you you can
that way control who gets to receive the
messages using attribute based access
control based on conditionals drawn from
the enterprise system so that
conditional right there might be faculty
can send mail to faculty that would be
an example of a rule if I had over here
a conjunction like if it's a faculty and
tenured like that then it's what's on
this side that gets included is the
encryption condition see so this is my
permission over here and this is my
address but if I want to send to the
female faculty I can encrypt under both
faculty and female okay that's what the
access structures give you with the
thresholds yeah in fact one of the main
things I wanted to show you for those of
you are interested in the cryptography
aspects I think this is one of the best
new practical applications of attribute
based encryption systems and we have
performance numbers based on CPA be e to
show exactly what the limitations are
for use in this application so I'll show
you some of those so yeah so that you
know the more complex the policies are
the more it costs you to
do this stuff and I'll show you how we
estimated that was actually one of them
kind of glad you asked because it's one
of the main things we did in the project
was looking at these performance
scalability questions and I was afraid
it's gonna bore everybody by showing it
to you
maybe I'll just savour some of you so
let's go into reading policy here so the
attribute authority issues Keys using
the enterprise database like it looks up
in the database whether I'm faculty and
then it says how long it thinks I can be
faculty for and gives me an expiration
key and so for example you can say
faculty and 1998 sorry 2008 if you say
faculty in 2008 then I'll have to have
both this sort of 2008 attribute and the
faculty attribute at the same time and
so you can issue a group of keys and
issue an expert attribute and then if
people want to use expirations on things
they can crudely expire things and then
you use disjunctive normal forms to
define the reading policy and this is
the target encryption that you're going
to use on the messages okay
so this is going to provide you with
your protection against a compromised
MTA for example now the system looks
like this I wanted to give you a high
level architecture and then I'll do the
three protocols and so the high level
architecture is that you have your usual
MTA in our case this was the University
of Illinois exchange server in other
words no change to the MTA at all you
have a web server that supports a B a B
M okay you need a little bit of client
software for the keys but not for the mu
a the mu a in our case was we use
several outlook and Firefox and so on
then you need an attribute authority to
issue the keys that we had to code
entirely ourselves well we used a
library from SR AIA for this then they
have a back-end support system that does
everything special in such a way as to
try to avoid changing things much in
particular on the back end you have of
course the enterprise database which you
need to access for the attributes and
then our particular ingredient is the
thing called the ABM server up here
which is kind of the
of the system and it uses a policy
description for a decision point which
may be on the ABM server or it may be
somewhere else and so this policy
decision point is the thing that holds
the policies for like who can send
messages the system is divided into
three protocol groups that we call the
policy specialization path the messaging
and address resolution path and the
attribute keying path and I'll just give
you a sketch of how each one works
particularly to show how the system
avoids changing the existing enterprise
system or clients since that was one of
the major deployment objectives so in
the policy specialization path this is
how you compose an ABM address and also
get your permission to send the message
okay and so the way you do this is the
sender goes to the enterprise
authentication server and gets a token
at the University of Illinois we have
some special thing called bluestem that
does this it could be Kerberos or
something else okay so you know sam'l or
whatever enterprises use and then you go
to the ABM server with this
authentication and the ABM server then
goes into the database here and derives
using the policy decision point you hear
it gets information about you your
attributes then it refers them to the
policy decision point which comes back
with your specialized policy what you
can do
represented as a webpage in our case
where you can kind of click things
saying this and this and this and then
within the sorry this or this or this
and then within those this and this and
this okay so something fairly simple to
use and so be easy to cobble up the
address for you know female faculty
that's not hard to write you know for me
to use that as easy in in its guts it
becomes an XPath and so the email
addresses will be basically XPath
expressions this one is the address
resolution so this is how you send email
so there's one little compromise in here
to avoid changing the
MTA and MUA and it goes like this which
is that thing where I got the xpath what
I do is I save it into a file we call it
a dot ABM file though I'm sure that's
taken already but the dot ABM file is
your address and so what you do is you
send your message to UI you see it ABM
dotted you know that ABM dot you at UIUC
dot e-d-u so a special address is
allocated for the ABM messages and you
have an ABM attachment which is then
taken to be the address okay so the
address is then resolved by the server
using the database and so in the address
list is the female faculty then you
would go in here and find the female
faculty they would be returned as a list
of addresses so this is your dynamic
listserv then this would be sent with
Microsoft Exchange through an interface
that's available for that that basically
creates a dynamic listserv for just this
message and then that sent out to all
the recipients like this the encryption
is done at the sender basically bike
encrypting a file you say you take an
attachment you encrypt it we have a
binary function and none of this is all
this fairly clunky stuff a command-line
thing but what you do is you take your
ABM address file that you just created
together with the the recipients that
you want I'm sorry the ABM address
together with your message body and then
you run this function and it uses this
package to encrypt it and then that sent
out and on this end we have software to
decrypt it okay and also give you some
performance numbers on that stuff it's
any question on this one
back to this question if I that if
you're in you can receive this if your
name is Bob or your female faculty
member yeah your encryption will branch
right you have to encrypt it both ways
because Bob is not a female faculty
member right doesn't know that system
girls can see yeah that's right right so
that's the magic of a te is that goes
that stuff right so I'm black boxing
this mainly for this talk because I
don't work on that cryptography stuff
but I appreciate it okay so it it does
for this application something that
nothing else could do okay so so that
your your right to hesitate on this and
say how would you actually do that and
so that's what it will do note in
particular too for like sending to
listservs you know often what you do is
you trust the lifts serve to have all
the keys of the recipients which in a
way throws out the baby with the
bathwater because I mean part of the
point of end-to-end encryption is that
you don't want the thing to remain on
the listserv in clear-text and so
trusting the listserv to do all the
encryption seems kind of pointless and
so here you encrypt end-to-end to a
collection of recipients that you don't
know who they are
yeah so you send out one copy but the
attributes allow you to decrypt it so
you don't have to do as in s/mime if you
would do this say there were a hundred
recipients you I don't know if there's
some specialization of this technique
but we would typically have like a
hundred encrypted session keys included
with the message and then you would send
it to all of them and they would find
their session key right so in this case
you don't have to do that so when you
come here to the attribute authority the
receiver comes to the attribute
authority says I need some I need my
keys okay and so it goes to the database
and it gives them their keys back up
here to the receiver and I'll miss
cueing a few little security points here
the authentication to the a a is done
with the law I already talked about that
the attribute the enterprise
authentication server does that I'm
assuming here that you have also an
identity certificate for s/mime purposes
like an x.509 search
then you use that to decrypt the message
okay and get your copy alright and so I
have my own special faculty key I'm not
sure if we thought bob was an attribute
but if we did you know I'd have my own
special Bob key as well okay so then the
the message from the MTA that you
received is this decrypted you know
using those attribute keys now looking
at this process the an obvious question
was how big an enterprise could do this
right and so what we wanted to do to try
to calibrate it was to go for a
middle-sized
enterprise with ordinary machines so
it's kind of the way something like the
University of Illinois would be as your
email server is just a fairly ordinary
machine nothing very special maybe you
know not like a supercomputer or
anything and so we were interested in
like how much could you support with
just kind of ordinary machines so I I
don't describe the machines here but the
kind of stuff that you might have on
your desk so we wanted to measure the
costs on each path and estimate the
latencies for mid-sized enterprises and
conjecture here what kinds of policies
might you use now this is one of the
hardest parts and I kind of partly
pushed I don't know if any of you are
interested in this but I do a lot of
this kind of policy stuff and
scalability and so a question you always
get is is this really scalable and the
answer is hard it's hard to answer
because nobody uses ABM now so how do I
know what kind of messages they're gonna
want to send okay and so we had to come
up with some idea how we could crudely
test this given that we have nothing to
go to and say oh here's our experience
with listservs and that's going to tell
us how to do these dynamic ones or
whatever okay come on we use this
Bethencourt Sahai and Watters
implementation of this cipher text
ciphertext policy a/b e-library for this
they did a first version for us we used
got some performance numbers found some
ideas on how to op
my eyes told them they did a second
version of it including more
optimizations but there were trade-offs
between encryption efficiency and key
generation efficiency that they
exploited to improve in a direction that
turned out to be the opposite of the
direction we needed and so their second
version of the system was slower than
their first version which basically says
that you have to kind of look at the
applications to tell what you need to
optimize on in this space and we don't
know this yet I think a big bottleneck
here is key generation ok so this is the
policy specialization times and so the
way we did this was for lack of any more
inspiring way we would basically
generate random policies and so you
would say something like I want you know
to have five terms and I want each one
of the sub term each one of the terms to
have five literals or up to five
randomly chosen and so you would get you
know like a cross section of this
depending on what you chose it would
generate a certain collection of random
policies the paper has details but what
popped out of this was we got 143 rules
in this random manner for one version
then 282 rules in the next version and
so on and so we've got this rough graph
which shows that if you wrote 443 rules
then it would take less than a second to
decide what the users policy is whereas
if you're up here at 674 rules it might
take 12 seconds to do that and so
somewhere in here there's some kind of
like patience gap where you might say
you got to optimize this or people are
gonna be you know if fed up with waiting
or you might have to put in something
saying like we'll give you your app
we'll send you your address by email or
something like that and so you do have a
bottleneck here it's not clear to me
you're likely to have 674 policies 674
rules okay so I thought this was kind of
on the high end and that 143 was not a
bad estimate for what you might have but
then again who knows right so it depends
on the organization
and what kind of attributes were talking
about okay so now we did studies with
the database we did two databases we did
this was Microsoft sequel server the
sequel and we also we chose this the
Microsoft 2005 because you could also do
XML with that okay so we wanted
something that would do both and so this
is with Microsoft's sequel server and we
did it in two versions with the access
control and without it to try to at
least look and see how much are you
paying for you know doing the security
stuff okay and the security introduced
an overhead here that you can see this
is a sort of 95 percent confidence range
and that's in milliseconds and this is
with an organization of 60,000 when we
went out Rand our random thing the
average list size that is when you're
sending one of these attribute based
messages the average list have 351
people on it okay and so you know to do
the resolution of the list to find those
351 people you know took between 180 and
359 milliseconds which seems quite
reasonable to me on the other hand the
XML one you know wasn't so good so there
you see here this is in the several
seconds range so your throughputs are
gonna be hit pretty hard by this I'm not
sure you care much about latency here
because this is like I send the message
if it's delayed by seven seconds you
know how urgent could it really have
been right so on the other hand
throughput might be an issue you might
need a know sort of highly provisioned
part of the reason we were thinking of
this is that when you imagine the useful
information in the organization that
could be used for the messages if you
think broadly of everything as opposed
to just what's in the HR database it
makes the thing enormous Lemoore useful
and you see you know lots of specialized
applications
now have bits of this kind of logic in
them you know like schedules have this
where you invite participants and so on
and so if you could really mine all that
stuff and view it under one conceptual
framework as an XML database it would
make the thing enormous lis more useful
and so that's why we thought this thing
would be interested we we saw some
presentations people gave on the idea of
like using XML to characterize the
entire information I don't know if you
work on this sort of thing or not but
you know look at the entire information
infrastructure of the organization and
give it an XML schema and then you have
like all of the underlying databases
would be in there different diverse
technologies but XML would allow you to
unify those all in a single thing now
encryption is done on the client and so
I don't think it's very performance
concerning we do have numbers so this is
if you have a lot of relation literals
then you're going to cost yourself for
that this is equality literal so you can
see here it kind of at the high end
if I have six equalities and six you
know relations like you know it's more
than twenty one years old for this and
as a faculty member for that then it's
going to cost you about four point six
three seconds on average to do the
encryption which you know maybe that
would try some people's patience but I
don't think it's that bad okay and the
decryption times were about a third of a
millisecond so almost negligible right
send a message to the if you want to
send to the faculty that would be an
equality that took about half a second
that's where I fight you know five
hundreds in a second
with a little bit of the same key but
that's that's very simple so there's
just one key in that case right as
opposed to a complex of keys okay so
that seemed actually quite good this is
with the slower version of cpab II so
like I said they changed it around we
were finding this stuff was no problem
okay it's the other stuff that we
haven't had bottlenecks I'll show you
that in a minute okay so this is the
generation of keys and this was more
significant so here this is with
numerical attributes and boolean
attributes and we're doing it again from
0 to 6 but in our system our underlying
system had a hundred attributes and so
you know we're talking about like that
this is assuming that suppose only six
attributes are used in a given message
then I only need those six keys okay so
it's kind of reasonable to have a small
number so although there are a hundred
attributes maybe I don't need them all
hundred at once if I did need them all
hundred at once then you can project out
what these figures might look like okay
if you're going for like six of them you
can see here a few seconds is required
to get them and so I'm going to the
server asking for these six keys it'll
take me a few seconds to get them okay
that's right this is on the fly but you
could you know have it generate them in
advance maybe you know it well there's
no problem with having to generate them
in advance so I get a message and it's
been an a B a B M encrypted our a B e
encrypted for a B M and so I say oh I
need the keys for this now we didn't do
anything fancy with this and there's a
little bit of a thing here which is you
know remember I said earlier there's a
question of whether you know whether
you're on a list so one of the decisions
we made was you know whether you're on a
list because it has to tell you what
keys you need and so in particular the
access structure under which the thing
is encrypted has to be included in the
message
in addition to the xpath you know so so
anyway the the information about or
rather derived from the XPath so any way
you would be able to tell why you got
the message or you could have gotten in
several different ways you might be
you're both in one group and another but
you would then be able to choose the
collection of keys with which to decrypt
it and so this is measuring how long it
would take you to get them if you got
them just at that point okay and so it
gives a kind of general measure of how
hard this ABM the attribute this this is
one thing nobody has worked on that I
know of is the performance concerns for
an attribute authority if you were to
have one for attribute based systems
that has attribute based encryption and
so these are giving some clue and so
what these are is different measures of
the window of vulnerability that you
might have for the system based on how
long am I going to be able to keep a
faculty key with an expiration even if
I'm not a faculty member anymore okay so
you know I've done some Highness crime
in the classroom and they have kicked me
out immediately but I still have this
faculty key okay now I'll note that just
because I have the key doesn't mean I
get the message right and so there's a
great deal of risk mitigation here but
if you're really paranoid about it then
you want short windows of vulnerability
like maybe you'd like me out of the
system today so if you want me out today
then we can support an organization of
10 users for this kind of thing and so
you know this is I'm cueing a lot of
details here about like how big you know
a lot of parameters are missing from
this chart but the point is that you
know if I'm insisting on refreshing the
keys every single day then you know for
most different combinations like this is
30 string attributes and ten numerical
attributes if I have to rekey that many
per day per individual across an
enterprise like I said this is a sixty
thousand person enterprise with a
hundred attributes per person then I
would be able to do ten of them in a day
okay so I have sorry I'd be able to do
ten use
I'm sorry it's not 60,000 people it's
the hey well I can support 10 hey I'm
sorry is it in thousands yeah 10,000
users thank you yeah that was kind of
important wasn't it it's more scalable
but I'm getting a credit for so up here
though you can do quite well of course
if it's just a month so that's that's
not too bad but I would say this one is
representing a real bottleneck if you
wanted to rekey every minute or
something like that you know that would
greatly impact the you know capability
that you would have so but I do believe
that rekeying on a monthly basis should
be reasonable because you're talking
about the rare instance where someone is
revoked and they keep a key for messages
that they're not supposed to get and
you're worried about their breaking into
the system and getting other people's
messages for a month you know so I don't
know you know I guess it depends on the
organization may depend on the
attributes to reverse non-expiring
message and you can make a bugger fix on
your key server you risk enveloping all
of those messages oh yeah what are these
things in kind of interesting aspects of
the system is you know what about
keeping old keys right could I have an
email and I go away on my you know trip
to climb Mount Everest and I get back
and my email bin bin is full of messages
I can no longer decrypt you know so you
know how what about how you're going to
keep all the keys you don't have really
old messages and you know it's not
issuing those kinds of keys anymore or
whatever okay a logical way in this
application to do this it seems to me is
to have a reasonable expiry on how long
before you you know how many keys you're
going to keep and to do something like
when I read a message I rien crypted
under my identity key and put it back in
the database so that way you know you
don't keep things in the attribute
encryption in the in the system so you
just have a rien ssin of that and
so your old messages are always
encrypted under your identity
certificate okay but one could imagine a
lot of different way
of trying to cut that up you know
depending on what kind of size you're
trying to support for this all right now
let me talk a little bit with the
security and privacy analysis of the
system there is a question of how you
enforce these policies for sending
receiving and reading an important one
in the first version of this system we
had the idea that we were going to sign
the ABM addresses and then you would
send something with a signed ABM address
and then it would have like a time stamp
on it and this would help us avoid
things like trying to rely on the
security in you know the exchange server
or whatever it is making sure that the
user who logged in is using their you
know privileges to send the message out
and so we found after the performance
numbers that you could really probably
do this more easily just by letting the
ABM message the ABM addresses be public
and unsigned that is anybody can put
them on their webpage or do whatever
they want with them and then you issue
them to people to help them make them
but then you also check them when they
send the message and so basically
they're checked both at the time they're
issued and at the time they're sent at
the time they're issued you only check
them to help the user make sure that
they're not composing something that
won't get delivered so these are always
checked dynamically using s/mime so what
you do is you authenticate to the the
ABM server using s/mime and then the s
mine uses that name to do the check to
see if you are allowed that send policy
now the vulnerability windows are
actually rather interesting one thing is
when something expires the receive might
be a subset of the read in other words
more people might be able to read it
than could receive it it makes no sense
to have more people who can receive it
than can read it that we kind of silly
to do that you just receive an encrypted
message that you would be frustrated to
find you couldn't decrypt but it makes
sense in many cases to
have the read policy exceed the receive
policy and in fact this is one of the
most interesting things I thought in
this thing that I haven't really
investigated much and I'll just give you
a little example suppose you're sending
you know a message to Sally's attending
physician then you might be able to
encrypt under those attributes but it
might make more sense to just encrypt
under the doctor attribute since then
most of these enterprise applications
the doctors have access to everything
anyway and you just need to make sure
that that is not available
on an external server to you know a non
doctor in your organization and so
having reading policies that are
possibly way larger than receiving
policies might be the most practical way
to do this it's just that you'll need a
whole new raft of policy stuff to figure
out what that should be you know for the
client caching is no problem so it helps
me form a file which is like an address
that I could put in my address book okay
so you know you could imagine extending
the address books to include
ABM addresses so like the female faculty
if I need to regularly send to them I
could have that in my address book the
the caching on the other end like you
know I want to kind of remember that
this guy has permission to use that to
avoid having to recheck it we did that
at first and then decided that we didn't
need to a principal that we tried to
apply is whenever possible let the
database do the optimizing and so we
were trying to assume that if something
is frequently requested from the
database the database is smart enough to
know how to make sure you can get that
quickly and so if people are often
routing on faculty a female faculty then
the database should be able to tell you
the female faculty quickly I may be
people who know more about database
optimizations can tell me if we were
unwise in that rely
but that that was a principle that we
tried to follow this particular example
your five invoice the email based on the
current policy and then was that email
you that you have to follow yes and one
month later I can send that email yes
that's how am I gonna recheck if I sent
it I don't have to go back to the ABM
spot policy specialization system but I
have a risk that it'll be rejected so if
it's been a year that it's been sitting
in my draft folder you know then it
might be I no longer have the privilege
to send that because of possibly policy
changes at the organization as well as
changes that might have occurred from my
attributes okay so generally I would
guess that what's going to happen is
you're going you know it's again one of
these things I don't know what people
are gonna end up using something like
this for a likely kind of thing is sort
of CRM like messages where you need you
know some administrator or someone in
charge of something is broadcasting a
message seems less likely to me it'll be
for discussion groups for example but
the then what would happen is that you
know I'm a person who often needs to
tell something to the female faculty
then you know I would just keep that
address and I would know whether or not
I continue to have access to it
okay if the MTA or the ABM server is
compromised you lose who sent what to
whom but not the contents of the
messages okay that's what bab-ee does
for you the clients if you have a
compromised client you lose the
information sent to that client and
anything that they can get through a
compromise that can use their keys if
you get two clients you get the union of
the two clients but no more than that
because of the collusion resistance and
so if I compromise a you know a CS
faculty member and I compromise a
tenured fat you know an assistant
professor in CS and a tenured professor
in ECE I still don't have enough to get
the messages to the tenured faculty in
CS okay so that's what those productions
were made and then concerning privacy
this is one where what we did was when
we were four
to do something because it seemed like
we needed to to make this work we did it
otherwise we didn't try to do anything
fancy in our implementation you don't
get to know who the recipients are but
you do get to know why you received a
message okay now here's a little bit of
the related work attribute based
addressing frit actually if we found a
patent on this a patent application I
don't know if it's successful
so this crowd right here attempted to
patent attribute based messaging they
call it attribute based addressing and
it was exactly the same thing as what
we're proposing here which is now their
application was CRM and so they wanted
you know of course if you're doing CRM
things you want your addressing to be as
targeted as possible so as not to dull
your customers you know an interest in
the messages you're sending and so they
they proposed an integrated system for
using a now what's what's very different
about this is that although they're
using ABM they didn't do anything with
security and they don't even have a
security concern in a sense because it's
like someone who has his CRM list and
he's going to be able to do what he
wants with that so what our work adds to
this is the these security dimensions
particularly and intra enterprise use
role based messaging for medical
applications is another thing that's
quite close and I talked about the
difference between roles and attributes
there's really quite a gray area so you
might think of some roles as being
determinable from attributes and so when
you have a way of getting a role from an
attribute then you could use our stuff
to do role based messaging if you think
of the roles as something outside of the
system that you can't get access to then
you might not be able to do it then
there's a back for trust management I
mentioned a B e for imposing access
controls part of the logic for a B E is
you can take your access control system
and use encryption to impose it on
somebody else so like if I hand out some
data to someone else then the encryption
enforces access control rules on that
data and that's sort of what we're doing
with the MTA in effect okay now here's
some more work we've done we had a
project called WS email that was sort of
the earliest part
to this this was looking at what would
happen if you redid email in terms of
web services our particular study here
was to look at using dotnet to implement
our new version of email in which you
know messages are not using SMTP they're
using soap they're not using s mime
they're using XML D cig and so on and so
we built a WS email system on net for
this and studied performance numbers
reasoning about security we also did a
system adaptive policies which was email
where you can explain what your policy
is to public and then they can react to
it so if you don't take attachments
above a certain size you can tell them
so that they don't have to send a
message and then call you on the phone
and ask you if you got it and then
another one with Shibboleth RSS we built
a version of Shibboleth to do CDA health
alerts where you go and you give them
your attribute credentials and it
determines the feed that you get and so
if you're like you know if there's a
Health Alert about a possible bird flu
outbreak you could have that feed go to
just say you know certain kinds of
doctors that would be you know the ones
you would first inform of something
before you scare the public with an
announcement my abdic is an effort to
use existing database trigger mechanisms
in particular in my sequel in order to
implement using fine-grained access
control attribute based access control
in other words try to make attribute
based access control be implemented with
the existing database support mechanisms
reflective database access control I
mentioned already and you can Google us
here I wanted to say a little bit of
about our application spaces that we
were interested in just to give you a
little bit of idea kind of how we're
trying to test the work one of them is
energy management systems so this is an
interest of mine that I'm not talking
about today particularly security for
the power grid one of their big problems
in that space is operator vendor access
to substations so they can check it's a
little bit like and I think of this my
PC does this call home to Microsoft to
check for updates
so on it's hard to do something like
that in the control system space because
of their efforts to isolate the systems
and so a big problem there is to figure
out how you're going to update you know
these systems in a reasonable way and so
this would be allowing you to do things
like a Switzer engineering lab engineer
gets an attribute that allows him to get
a role to go and look at the
configuration of a Switzer engineering
lab relay in a substation so we're
trying to develop a system to do that
kind of thing and then healthcare is an
obvious application area where we might
be able to apply this doctors really
don't want to worry about things like
who gets the message so there's fairly I
mean they definitely want it to be got
to the right people but they would
prefer themselves not to have to know
the details and so they have fairly
substantial systems in which you might
say quote something in voice text and
then someone transcribes it and figures
out the rules for where that's message
is supposed to go and then how the thing
is supposed to be checked and so one
thing you might hope for is more
automation so if I have some sort of
rule that says that this has to go to
the attending physician the primary care
physician and the ordering physician
then you know you would be nice if you
could just say that as opposed to like
trying to resolve who those are before
it makes the message on the other hand a
major trend in this space as I went
trying to sell this idea to people a
major trend in these hie s is to try to
get out of this messaging orientation
and so what they want to do is to to
probably know more about this than I do
but you know they want to take all the
data put it in one place and give
everybody access to it and so like a
state might say all the people in the
states are supposed to get their MRI
readings from one place and then we put
all that data in a database and then
everybody gets access to that database
and this is how we get rid of this
messaging stuff and this REIT runs into
legal challenges with privacy you're
creating a big pool of people's data
that can be accessed by lots of
different people unless you put it
access control on it and so there's some
interesting questions about how you're
going to describe that access control
thing I quoted earlier about the access
control matrices written with attributes
was something I saw in the trade press
about this hie s suggesting to people
that might be a good way to write down
their policies okay so the email
messaging based on attributes is
feasible and deployable in mid-sized
organizations we didn't try to find out
what would happen if the organization
were really big but I think it could be
done we did in the case of Shibboleth
RSS think about what happens with inter
domain issues but here a lot of that
stuff is of course related to the
possibility of having attributes that
means something to both me and to
another organization and and so once
you've figured out how to do attribute
mapping then you know maybe the
scalability things can just be sort of
you know put on top of that like if you
have two organizations of 60,000 and
we've proved it's scalable to 120,000
then it will work access control
policies and encryption are manageable
using these attribute based security
mechanisms I think these policies
they're kind of simple but I think that
they're intuitive I mean I don't have
any trouble giving many examples of
these things and people give the
examples back to me including some
clever ones I gave this lecture last
Friday and it was at University of Texas
at San Antonio and someone asked if they
could send an email message to all of
the faculty but one the one that they're
complaining about is they want to know
if the system could support negation so
this is one we never thought about but
yeah maybe you want something like that
so that you know there there are a kind
of you know richer collection of
policies from message messaging that you
might imagine here and the examples can
be quite intuitive
yeah now the way that so here's one of
their big problems is that they don't
want to put like the permissions into
the edge devices because then they have
a big management problem with the
permissions in the edge devices so they
want the permissions to be more like say
Kerberos like or with you know something
more centralized and so we're trying to
develop an approach in which you have a
policy decision point outside of the
substation and then the policy
enforcement point is the relay so that
that is that you know Switzer s relay
does the roles and an hour decision
point you know is based on attributes
and it does the decision so that that's
the architecture we were aiming for it's
so this stuff the this is fairly
rudimentary right now what they have you
know with kind of heavy perimeter
protections and then fairly vulnerable
edge devices and so our project the more
global project but I'm not switch I'm
not talking about today is to look at
ways of trying to make the thing more
protect it at the edge rather than so
much dependent on perimeter and
isolation protections some example AB -
officer of a bank switch for making to
look at customer records as long as
within the National border of
Switzerland but he can't at these
anywhere else the world so would you be
able to do a look-up on most of the
characteristics to determine the
recipients for them introduce some
dynamic attributes that we could
introduce deny situations well you
everything so the sending policies could
perhaps do that you might have a an
attribute of like location
obviously went okay to them they were
already dead at UPMC miss Tibet disco
you know today I can tomorrow you have
window of vulnerability challenges with
the keys but but with respect to the
attribute checks it's not that hard so
if if it provided the system knows it
has to have some way of knowing you know
so if assuming it knows where I am I I
could I think that that could be
programmed an yeah I think we can do
that with what we have now that can be
an attribute what we did was we got from
the University of Illinois a description
of its HR database contents and then we
kind of made up some other stuff and we
did some statistical things saying
here's what we think are the likely you
know some attributes everybody has some
are very sparse and we did some
estimates from that but we didn't focus
on this question of like very dynamic
attributes like location of the sender
so if there I mean the Switzerland ones
when I know about that you know they're
very fussy about where you are when you
do your transactions banking wise for
various international legal reasons and
such or actually Swiss legal reasons I
believe right the but we didn't have a
long list of such things there were
other ones you know when I'm thinking of
the application areas military folks
kind of resonated with this because you
might send things based on things like
security levels so you could send
messages you know based on recipients
that that had levels that you know
relate to yours and interesting ways so
yes let's come a little I weighed in
looking to need to tail with that but it
seems interesting you can send it to
how dose a salary less than people
socialism is it asked by gender that I
was could be yeah so if you got a set of
rules that said you had complete
permission then the way the thing would
look is that you would have a list of
all the attributes in the system and you
could select and then within each one of
those you could go in and that's the
disjunction and then with each one of
those you could go in and select a
conjunction this is the addressing
capability so if you had like rules that
find lots of attributes to people they
would have a big webpage with you know a
hundred things that they could work with
that you know to two levels look at any
other features from other databases yes
their DVDs yes yes we I have a list I
haven't we have a paper on that and it
has the list of the ones that we checked
so we started with Oracle VPD and what
we were interested in was the idea of I
create policies in the database and you
create policies in the database and then
how those interact and you get some very
interesting problems with respect to I
run a query at either my privilege or
your privilege but you get to say it my
privilege but you get to rewrite it in
the VPD and then what happens is that it
can leak information of mine because
you're now running at my privilege and
we sent this to Oracle and they at first
said they thought it might be a bug but
then they wrote back and said well we
just have one database administrator and
everybody trusts them so this isn't
really relevant so there's a skate I
mean so I understand why they do it like
that but as a scalability question of
wouldn't it be better if you could have
policies that are you know more
distributed and the other point was that
they you know we weren't doing it right
so we hadn't programmed it correctly so
there was a different way of doing it we
didn't know about which made us
appreciate that it's a it is tricky and
so that's why we wanted to look at this
formal language
stuff yes we checked Microsoft Swan has
the same issues that we found and sent
and one or two others so that we check
the mic hi this is Lars Olson as the
student working on this and he's the
databases person and I asked him to make
sure he looked at the major vendors and
tried to find out you know as much as
possible whether the same problem would
arise in the other products
no that's paper we just submitted two
CCS but I'm willing to share it with you
if you like well I if if Lars doesn't
mind I think he would be happy to share
it no we didn't consider that we in fact
one thing we did was we first did a
simple version with XPath so the idea
was just to do no more than XPath and
then they came out with the encryption
stuff and we found that we told them you
know you can do exactly XPath you know
so your your encryption can you know
take these XPath things and encrypt with
them I don't know there might be some
generalizations there all the time
working on generalizations like at this
year's CCS there was one on revocation
so this thing has a very simple model of
revocation and then we work with these
vulnerability windows well there is no
revocation in this system we see
yeah
or how about works for equals Bob Dean I
will send a female to everybody who
works for Bob except for Frank cause
it's a birthday party yeah right on you
listen was an appealing example of that
everybody yeah your key servant has to
go do it just reboot your keister
generate a whole new community oh yeah
this is one of the things I thought was
kind of crazy about the system is if you
look at some of these more complex ones
it's clear you don't need all those keys
right so that's well that's why I
mentioned that thing about doctors which
was many cases it just seems like it
takes a lot more sense to have the
reading policy be a big envelope around
the receiving policy and so that would
be a you know kind of next generation of
work on this is to figure out how you
describe the relationship between
reading and and receiving policies Oh
have we tried to kind of like simulate a
system over time no instead of
resolution anything like that
it would be you know it was something we
got up to the point where you could
actually just use it at the University
of Illinois but if you really were gonna
use it you know you'd have to make this
a lot more streamlined I mean it's it's
like using PGP you know it's very very
clunky and tiresome if you just use this
sort of you know command line encryption
and that sort of stuff and you know you
might have a directory that's full of
ABM files and you could go and pick the
one you need or something it's just an
attachment so that might be a you know
very crude thing you could do but the
the another thing that we didn't do that
would be obvious to do here is something
that dynamically gets the keys based on
what your messages are so in other words
you don't try and go and fetch these key
or something that compromises maybe it
pre fetches the keys when you know at
night or maybe it just gets them on
demand like you know you get a message
and you say oh I can't decrypt that
until I get these keys or maybe it does
both you know like it you know some
combination of those so but we didn't
try to do any of those kind of
experiments like with all of us trying
to use ABM and see what was the most
frustrating thing about it or anything
like that
oh another thing I'll point out too is
that you have a distinction between what
I would call voluntary and involuntary
attributes so you might have like an
interests database and people could
enter interests in it and you could
route on that database the more and you
could imagine combining that with
databases like gender in the HR database
which you could view as an involuntary
things so that are kind of pragmatic
things that if my group wanted to do
this we would be tempted to just have a
voluntary database to do it but you know
if you wanted to make it really
effective for kind of CRM like
enterprise applications you would need
to have involuntary attributes be
available if you make the reading scope
larger than the receiving scope and then
get somewhere else by another mechanism
then someone who shouldn't be able to
read it yes absolutely
so that's why let me give that medical
example again and explain that suppose
you have an organization and the rule in
most Hospital organizations is that all
the doctors have access to all the
patients the reason being that they
can't tolerate the privacy risks they
don't have any cost for the are very
little cost for but if a patient had an
emergency and the doctor couldn't get
their record they might get sued and so
that the decision is that the doctors
have to have access to everything on the
other hand if you send a message then
they might do something like you know
have it forwarded to Gmail and we
case you definitely don't want the thing
to go in clear-text
and so you need to encrypt but you don't
have to encrypt anymore than the policy
that they would get by going to the
system and trying to gather the data
directly in other words you don't need
the push policy to be any different from
the pull policy because if there was a
reasonable pull policy than the push
policy should be okay and so this push
call policy in this case is the reading
policy your your value or your
attributes are they assuming a single
value for each person can have five
states yeah you can have a numerated
ones yeah so it can support an
enumerated ones yeah so I can support
boolean enumerated and numerical ranges
sure I understand if you don't get it's
kind of a dynamic group in question and
it's if you get a subset of the whole we
we don't have well we don't we don't
have very much by way of like type
checking in the system to verify that
you're you know writing down something
sensible like you know you could write
you could send messages to empty sets
right so you could write down something
that couldn't possibly be the case you
know and and you wouldn't even know so
that right so you might imagine the
system we did consider various versions
in which the user would get some
feedback about the you know what you're
actually talking about like I wouldn't
want to think I have a message sent to
ten people that's actually being sent to
ten thousand so you know there's a
there's some risk associated here with
users miss
forming the queries and having
permission to do it or forming queries
that just don't make any sense like they
have combinations of attributes that
can't occur actually a partial
inspiration for this and you're actually
this is one thing we were very
interested in was that there would be
policies that people could manage and
part of our inspiration was that the HR
department of the University of Illinois
has a mapping like this already but it's
it's for the pull database not for the
push in other words it's if you're an HR
if you have this HR designation then
you're allowed to get access to these HR
records and so the thought was that
whatever you know they had a little
informal thing saying here's our rules
about like you know the if you're an
administrator in the computer science
department you have access to the HR
records of the computer scientists and
that kind of thing
very much like attribute based policy
them back to our attribute based
policies already and they have a list of
these things and we got to look at that
list and so the thought was let's try to
see if you could encode these kinds of
rules and so that the you could imagine
that the HR people would run this and
they would say well here's a set of pull
rules and so those could be push rules
although I don't know that they'd be the
same so but but but but it's not
impossible for them to manage it is it
is fair enough to say this thing of like
how are you going to manage these rules
seems pretty interesting but that's like
true for any of these attribute based
systems if it's not an explicit list of
people who have permission then you know
it's more it's there's some challenges
with that
it's at least better than manually
maintained lists
yeah I think that this is the kind of
broad agenda I was really kind of hoping
to push together today is you know the
next generation of these technologies
will have languages and analysis
techniques and algorithms that allow us
to avoid explicit extensional lists and
start to incorporate some of the more
informal management decisions into the
actual software because we thought you
know it seems like the thin end of the
wedge for questions about privacy so you
know maybe you could have a rule saying
nobody could push to anybody they
couldn't pull from so in other words in
other words you would make a risk
management decision that they could have
gone and found that in the database for
themselves and that was part of the
inspiration to for using this list from
the HR guys saying you know anything you
could have got access to by other means
you know we'll let you do it for the
dynamic mailing list